el nombre de nicolas sarkozy figura en
más de una decena de casos políticos
judiciales el que lo llevó este lunes a
la justicia es el caso escuchas acusado
de corrupción y tráfico de influencias
al ex presidente se le señala de haber
ofrecido al ex magistrado gilbert a
xivert un trabajo a cambio de
información sobre otro proceso el caso
bettencourt en el que se le acusaba de
haber aceptado pagos ilegales de la
heredera de l'oréal liliane bettencourt
para su campaña presidencial de 2007 en
este procedimiento fue acusado también
de aprovecharse de la debilidad mental
de la octogenaria heredera del emporio
de cosméticos en torno a esa campaña la
fiscalía investiga desde 2012 si sarkozy
habría recibido millones de euros del
fallecido gobernante libio moamar al
gadafi su principal acusador el
empresario franco-libanés ziad
takieddine retiró este mes su versión
pero la justicia mantiene cargos por
asociación criminal corrupción pasiva
financiación ilegal de campañas
electorales y ocultación de fondos
públicos libios a finales de este mes
sarkozy deberá comparecer nuevamente
ante un tribunal por el caso víctima
lyon acusado de violar reglas de
financiamiento de campañas durante su
fallida candidatura a la reelección en
2012 la acusación asegura que el partido
de sarkozy oculto junto a la empresa de
relaciones públicas vigma lyon 20
millones de euros de los costos de su
campaña pero los problemas legales del
ex presidente no terminan ahí el 15 de
enero de este año la fiscalía financiera
de francia abrió una investigación
previa por tráfico de influencias y
presuntas actividades delictivas de
loving a favor de oligarcas rusos cuando
sarkozy fue asesor de una firma
aseguradora de ese país